well right now in new york there's an
eviction moratorium we own some forty
thousand dollars
what percentage of people really need it
and what percentage are milking the
system
how can government cover the criminals
thank you judge
he just gave me great speech who's
helping me you have to pay your mortgage
you have to pay for his bills i've been
saving every penny
to buy the house now it's like a
nightmare with this person
here he's scared about him is he gonna
come out of here with a baseball bat we
call the police many times
they say if we don't see blur we cannot
do nothing it's impacting everybody but
the small guys aren't gonna survive
we're so happy here we just want to live
in peace there are a lot of people going
through this situation you think
a lot i love it
good morning guys here in new york city
we have a very interesting story to get
into today so there's been a
eviction moratorium put in place due to
the pandemic so basically
tenants have been able to live in a
apartment or home without paying
rent if they've gone through hardships
due to the pandemic
now for some people this has been
necessary
and is honest but for others they're
milking the system
so today we're going to get into more of
the untold story the story of
the landlords what they're dealing with
especially the small ones who make an
income from this
they still have to pay their mortgage
they still have to pay taxes
yet they can take in rent we're going to
talk to some landlords
we're going to talk to some lawyers and
hopefully we're going to get talked to
some tenants
to get a better understanding of the
situation
[Music]
so tell us what's going on you're uh
you're a real estate lawyer i'm a real
estate lawyer
um i practice landlord tenant law mostly
representing
commercial landlords okay residential
and residential and commercial okay so
what's going on i'm more focused on the
residential side for this video but
what's
what's going on currently can you give
us the nuts and bolts let's say of this
moratorium
evictions it's a new world for me for
most of my audience
so right now in new york there's an
eviction moratorium for anyone facing a
covet hardship
okay um meaning if you fill out a little
document that says that you've been
impacted by covid nobody checks nobody's
looking you don't have to prove anything
okay you are exempt from eviction
i can't start a case against you i if
there's a case already
that's been started that case is what's
called staid
okay i can't move forward on it so let's
say you've worked your whole life you've
bought a building
rented it out yep march 2020 comes
parker tenants stop paying rent okay say
okay
couple months right may 2020 comes
still haven't paid rent right your
mortgage payments are still due
your taxes are still due the taxes are
still due
but your tenants aren't paying rent
they're being told don't worry
you think landlords can't commence cases
you guys are good
yeah september 2020 comes still no rent
december january
may 2021 still no rent it's been 15
months since you've gotten rent
what percentage of people really need it
and what percentage are milking the
system would you think
it's a good question right or it's hard
to know because you can't qualify for
the governmental assistance if you paid
your rent
so they're kind of rewarding bad
behavior the only way you can get the
grant
is if you didn't pay so even if i can
show a hardship i lost my job if i paid
my rent i'm out
you're doing court completely online
right now court is completely online
this is the commercial part
this case was on for a hearing um it's a
restaurant that
the case is from 2019. okay they have
not paid rent
2018 2019. 2019 this case was in court
we did a payment plan with them assuming
they abided by the payment plan
we were more than happy to keep them if
they didn't abide by the payment plan
then the marshal will come and serve
marshall's notice
back in 2019 they didn't abide by the
payment plan
we moved to serve a marshall's notice
they came in to court and said don't
affect us don't evict us we'll pay
pandemic happen our court case didn't
get hurt it's now
june 17 2021 more than
probably two years since the
commencement of this case they owe
over a hundred thousand dollars this was
on for hearing
last week as to whether i can you know
enforce my warrant
and yesterday i got a hardship
declaration from them
saying kovid they're saying covet but
there's a problem before cody there's a
problem in 2018. are they still running
the restaurant right now they're still
there
restaurants open was open during the
whole pandemic for takeout
now i'm not saying they weren't impacted
right and i'm not saying we wanted
restaurants
but this isn't a big landlord it's two
brothers that own this commercial
property
100 000 it's a lot of money these are
all attorneys waiting for their cases to
be called
for him yeah i'm here judge is there and
you can see he's like in a virtual
background that's like not a real
background the judge the lower right
this is the judge
okay good morning can everyone hear me
yeah sure
this was on for a hearing and a hardship
declaration was filed that day
i think that's permitted no
you're shaking your head i mean there's
not much i could say right
it's permitted but is it is it is it
you know it's not really fair right
respondent said on
on the last court appearance that the
business was doing better and now we got
a hardship declaration
or we're not looking to evict anybody
but we're looking to get paid that's
it we're looking to pay them you know
the only thing i can do
is go by the letter of the law mrs elsa
which you know it doesn't say
that you have to file it by a certain
time or doesn't say that you can't
file it on the day of the hearing okay
so you know well i i certainly
understand your arguments
um i don't think there's a lot that i
can do at this point
all right so let's do 93 all right
okay thank you thank you judge
all right he just gave me a great speech
but that's exactly the point right and
the judge he understands
the issue and it's not fair but by law
there's nothing that he can do see if
you're gonna get a rental property you
would
say get one in new jersey is it
different over there go go to florida go
to jersey
uh virginia i heard is good
i mean save new york for big landlords
who can afford to
you know subsidize so then it's not big
this this is another case of the small
guy getting squashed
the big guy like you just said he can
weather this storm
for the most part i mean the real the
real big guys
but it's coming to an end for them too
right i have a
i have a building right now where the
tenants haven't paid rent
in over a year six hundred thousand
dollars it's a lot even for big guys
it's a lot of money
okay i have a commercial tenant in
harlem who owes two million
i don't care who you are that's a lot of
money yeah so it's impacting everybody
but the small guys aren't going to
survive
i don't think so sort of sort of the
story of the pandemic right
amazon accelerates right on this mom and
pockets
yeah smoked yeah
all right let's get out to some places
i'm going to uh
elon is picking me up right yeah all
right guys we're going to go out we're
actually going to go to queens
and uh check out first hand what the
situation is like
i put a face to the voice how you doing
nice to finally meet you meet you yeah
so i've arranged to uh to introduce you
to
two landlords where we're currently in
litigation the the the people you're
meeting today
they're both smaller landlords two three
four family homes
both the landlords are living in one of
the units together
with tenants in the other world
[Music]
among all the boroughs in new york
queens is known
for predominantly two three four family
homes uh these are smaller more intimate
settings
for apartment relationships between
landlords and tenants the landlord lives
on one floor
and the second floor has its own
entrance there's a tenant up there
sometimes you'll have a landlord that's
renting out a basement so these aren't
the big institutional investors
these are not big institutions these are
small family investments they rely on
these little properties
for their future retirement or
or to pay off kids college funds so did
you see that back there
there's a sign that says we buy homes
for cash is there a lot of that going on
there's a lot of that throughout the
city
and you know the more time is ending on
august 31st we
are not aware of it being extended yet
again but assuming it is not extended
starting september evictions continue
foreclosures continue
and i think that we're going to see more
cash for keys signs we're going to see
more
signs that we buy houses all cash and
it's going to be really directly
because so many people fell behind on
their mortgages
weren't able to pay uh pay down their
debts and and collect rents
to keep their properties above water so
do i gotta be stealthy here or can i
come in with you
i'm gonna give a call so whatever they
prefer you can
uh manage it we're talking to the
landlord right
first we're gonna speak to the landlord
and and their family first
all right from the catherine's uh mom
yeah very nice to meet you i can just
open up
julieta you're the the owner of this
place
the whole building
nice to meet you so how long have you
lived out here for uh
10 years we're so happy here we
we just want to live in peace
oh you got a jacuzzi back here yeah it's
like a yakuza
that's cool need some water in there of
course
no it's new huh you did it the story is
starting with the
before the pandemic so we uh
we're planning to we're planning to rent
a room so we can have more money to pay
our mortgage
so this person came and um
at the beginning he started to
like abuse us because he's like a
success what is that so such a bad
something like that
yeah he's like that okay is he gonna
come out of here with a baseball bat or
is he going to come outside with a
baseball bat
we call the police like that three times
or sometimes already
he discussed with the police at the
second time with you know
he's no easy guy so we are we scared
about him
we scare about with er be safe because
it's too much abuse
and also he has no respect for my
daughter
for my wife even for me no respect at
all
so he doesn't care what happened he's
very selfish man
he's not paying attention so he's
smoking marijuana
like crazy so he's smoking there so the
smokes goes upstairs see what we had to
sit down and
smoke with him also at the same time we
don't like it so this
these things is a like affecting
emotionally in in
and also physical because yeah because
we don't
we don't smoke money okay so walk us
through that don't know because i
i'm gonna sit next to you i honestly
didn't know this
um until these guys reached out to me i
had no idea what was going on i don't
think most people know what's going on
so what happened was there's a
moratorium on evictions right because of
covid
but the small mom and pop landlords that
you saved your money
you're paying a mortgage it's not like
you're rich if you were you wouldn't
have
tenants here and now and now you're put
in a position where you can't
you can't uh collect the rent exactly
and you can't do anything about it right
exactly huh i cannot do it
because he's not paying rent at all he's
coming like he owns the he owns the
house
and he's coming in back now he's coming
with the company before he was alone
now he's coming with somebody else every
day every day every now it's every day
he has no respect for us he doesn't care
so
yes this is our belongs to my daughters
so ah my daughter lives at the basement
did you make the add-on oh yeah you did
this okay nice
all right guys so you can see there's a
basement unit where the daughter lives
the tenant is above the daughter and
then
moses and julieta live yeah above here
yes we're going to go up there right now
okay
all good the attack dogs are downstairs
after you thank you
thank you oh my god i had surprise too
our dream home um so i been saving uh
every penny to buy the house
we dream and did we were so happy when
we get the kids and oftentimes said this
is our
dream american dream and now it's like a
nightmare with this
person in here where are you from
originally oh colombia
we came here like 42 years ago
working so hard for everything because
we come here to work
to work to plan in our future for
outdoors and uh
all the stuff and we come with the
situation
so it does make us our life difficult
very difficult
we are the peaceful family we like to be
with
harmony we like to be together no
problems but this
man is causing problems to us there's no
pain
14 months 14 months yes so he owns
40 000 so you he doesn't pay rent but
you have to pay your mortgage
exactly and they build the electricity
the water because
he brings a lot of company here so so we
have to
uh pay for the the bills that you have
to pay for his bills yes
yes we have to pay for his utilities
because he doesn't pay nothing
you pay taxes to the government right
property taxes we do every year we do
every year we pay taxes we paid
everything so we had to
get money uh i don't know where because
i'm not working i have only two days
working two days because the the job is
slow and you know let me explain
let me explain to him because this
problem he had a
small minister many stroke because of
the
the problem too much
kathy my daughter has to to work like 50
53 hours a week
so we can she can help us to do that she
lives on uh
the basement she has around there and
uh when he knows that she's there she's
he started to make
a lot of noise and he jumped uh his ways
and uh he he walks very
i mean very loud and he he did a lot
a lot of noise with the ladies there
he doesn't respect my daughter because
he lives
down our room also does he work he has
to work
come into jobs he has to so he's making
money he looks like
he has two he has two jobs he has one in
the morning and
one at night because he can't he has i
know his
schedule in the morning he comes like a
5 5 30 in the afternoon
so he got dressed and he goes so he's
making money doesn't have to pay the
rent
how do you feel about the system now you
came from another country
like what's your what are your thoughts
the system is is
is good and no good why is good because
it's helping the people cannot afford it
to pay the rent because they're pandemic
but some people are abusing about the
system
how come how come the the
the government um cover the criminals
because he's a criminal he's whatever
he's doing right now he's a criminal
and uh because uh he abuses us because
we are
all people well we're all people so he
thinks that we cannot do nothing
to him who's helping me tell me who's
helping me to
to to to fix the the situation
who's helping us what happened i don't
know why this is
this is overrun this is a wrong because
if they if they find a help to pay the
rent
why we don't know how fast to pay the
mortgage the bank expects it from you
yeah yeah and the government expects the
tax imagine that
it's so it's insanity i can't exactly
it's unbelievable
that it even exists right now this is uh
this is crazy
this is crazy i know the government is
is helping and it's doing
is doing too much i mean it's healthy
too yes but we don't get that help
because this man doesn't care to up
to fill it up the application to get
that money from the from the government
okay i'm gonna stop this video for a
second to say that there's nothing more
frustrating than when honest people
are getting worked over by unfair policy
so i've decided to set up a gofundme
page for the hanau
family to help with their legal fees
they would be very appreciative
any help you could offer to help out
with their legal fees which are not
cheap at this point a dollar five
dollars ten dollars whatever amount
i'm going to put that link below in the
description if you're feeling like you
want to help
there's the place to go back to the
video this is
a beautiful country yeah it is i'm i am
happy to live in this country my
daughters grew up in this country
so thanks for this concert we love this
country
and we have helpful in this country the
thing is the rules
the rules sometimes is is not we can
understand because
it's giving more time to the lazy people
use abusing the landlords have a new job
two jobs and because the
he's collecting money from the
unemployment rate and and
and also yes that's yeah that's true
so they suppose he's collecting money
from the unemployment and he can pay the
rent i know he can cover the
uh we know that the sneaker that he
wears like 700
or something like oh yeah because we
need help we are looking for a help
and we have a lawyer and we put all
everything in his hands and we are
hoping everything
be solved the judges as soon as possible
since the pandemic like a 14 months
already with this
problem go to sleep with 24 7
24 our mind we can sleep well like
before
we call the police many times we can
they say if i don't see if we don't see
blur
we cannot do nothing this is not fair
this is not bad
if they don't see blood blood yeah if
you're if we don't sleep blood blood on
you
so you have to attack them yeah exactly
we have to be attacked by the
tenants to uh to uh
making the police do children
[Music]
there are a lot of people going through
this situation you think a lot
over here is where the neighbors are
dealing with which is which house
this one yes okay the house the first
floor
is and the landlord lives at the second
floor
they are 73 years old they have
them a lot see nine people living there
nine people understand okay okay and and
we have only one can you imagine nine
people
like people yeah imagine them like
people living in the house
thank you both so much thanks for
speaking on camera thank you i feel much
better now
is here yeah so much better the the
pressure will begin on
on next week's hearing thank you and uh
somebody will finally hear your
complaints
thank you so much i appreciate that and
uh i hope
we finish with this you'll manage you
get right
thank you so much thank you moses god
bless
god stay strong have a wonderful day
thanks for coming bye-bye thank you both
do you have any tenants that are
sort of camped out in your place without
paying rent
so we're going into carnage yes we as a
small landlord we are suffering from
this situation
jesus what about us she hasn't paid
since 2019. but however
she has luxury and design items louis
vuitton
housing court in new york city is the
worst
it's a sense of fairness you know just
be fair at the end of the day they would
rather
see a small landlord lose their home
people come in with like
kittens and they leave like lions what
do you guys have to say to the
government or whoever's creating these
policies what do you want to say